Hello everybody!
Hello everyone.
We are here for the season 20 Apex launch.
Oh, there's a lot of big changes going on here.
And despite everything...
Sorry, I'm like super rusty.
I haven't played Apex in a long time!
Oh my god.
But a lot of things have changed for this game.
I'm like, honestly, I'm like really, really excited to
actually play the official release of it because like I play
tested this release a long time ago and I can find it.
I've been keeping it a secret for a while.
So it's so cool that it's finally in.
And for those who are wondering what the biggest change is
like the MOBA shit they did you can your armor is connected
to your upgrades so you can pick one or the other so like
I've seen this for a while now so I'm so I I debated about
streaming today but I've I just want a game I just I didn't
obviously use the circumstances I didn't sleep a lot I think
I had like three hours to sleep and then I've been awake for
a while now.
I was like, do I do what I do?
And honestly, gaming has always been like a huge comfort for
me and especially Apex.
Apex is like one of my biggest comfort games and like no
matter, oh my god, I'm sorry.
No matter what happens, like I always default to Apex
because it really, oh my gosh, it has like helped me a lot
like dealing with my emotions because I just, especially
Apex, because Apex has been always been my ultimate comfort
game whenever I'm sad.
helped me a lot especially by playing Apex with people and
it really helped me a lot in general so that's why I decided
I was like I'll stream Apex and I didn't want to be alone
and I want to say a huge shout out to all my friends that
stayed up with me last night making sure I was safe and all
people making sure I was safe making sure everything was
okay so I just want to say I can't really say who they were
are publicly but I just want to say like a huge thank you to
all my friends that stayed up with me last night and just to
make sure I had people around so I'd be okay and everything
and that's why I stream today.
I wanted to stream because I didn't really want to be alone
and I always enjoyed playing Apex.
I always enjoyed playing Apex and it's like I said it's
something I've enjoyed doing and always cheers me up.
And for those obviously I can't say much about the current
situation because my lawyer is making sure I'm safe.
So, um, I can't really say much.
For now, I just wanna pew pew.
I have not played Apex in a long time.
So, it's gonna be rough.
It's gonna be very fucking rough, obviously.
So, I'm gonna get shit on, especially when I feel like
there's a lot of, oh shit, there's a lot of of people coming
back right now and i feel so rusty at the moment um so yeah
uh yeah anyway i heard like okay i don't really remember a
lot of the upgrades but this one was like you can see
batteries and stuff and then increases tactical range gain a
tactical charge but have shield regeneration like shit like
that like that shit like you can't find armors on the ground
anymore apparently Um, so that, I don't know, I guess like
that makes it so it's less lucky, like it's less RNG, so you
can't find armor on the ground anymore, and, uh, it's all
about, like, upgrading your armor, yeah, like, shooting your
gun, or, like, finding, like, XP boxes, like, these XP boxes
and shit that will guarantee, like, free upgrade, and stuff
like that, or, like, like, abilities or something.
Yeah, like this new season is a lot of changes.
And apparently rank, it resets everybody to, like, zero or
one.
Sorry, one.
So every rank starts off at rank one or rank one point.
Sorry, not rank one.
But, like, starts at one point.
So, Preds will be in the same lobby as, like, bronze players
and shit like that.
Which is, like, sucks as a bronze players.
And then, like, I remember I was telling one of my friends,
I was like, I was like, oh my god, I was like, oh my god,
no, we're gonna, like, what if we, what if we get in a game
with all these Pred players?
And then my friend was like, you do know the percentage of
Pred players in the apex population, right?
And I was like, wait, and then they were like, yeah, there's
more, there's more gold plat players playing this game than
there are.
are pred players you do know that right i was like oh my god
wait i forgot pred is one percent of the population so like
i was like oh my god there's real people playing this game
it's been you know after being like in sbmm lobbies for so
long i forgot there are like actual people that play this
game and not the D-Gen low-lice like me.
I was like, oh my god, there's a dad out there.
There's a dad out there who just got home from work that's
booting up his favorite Apex Legends game that's like in
bronze right now and then he's gonna get absolutely farmed.
I was like Holy shit They exist
Look I've been in like SBMM lobbies for So fucking long now
For those who don't know what SBMM is It's like I don't
remember the full names That was something match What was it
called?
Okay I don't even remember the full name But it's basically
like where you're in the lobby with your skill level sorry
my brain's not working when you're going around with three
hours of sleep
but so I forgot what it's like to play with and against real
people and with jobs who have like nine to five jobs and
like is playing this game as a hobby and is also not a freak
controller roller demon freak I forgot what that is like oh
skill based matchmaking yes that's what i mean i forgot
that's what it was like so i was like holy but this is only
in rank though like i'm gonna be playing some trios i don't
know i won't play rank because i don't want to get farmed by
i don't want to be the dad that gets farmed by the brand boy
in solo so like i was like oh that's now
just gonna do some trios but yeah i i know there's like oh
shit how do i change heroes again it's been a while oh m all
right oh you can tell how long when was the last time i've
touched this account um i saw like octane has some cool ones
did my game crash oh it was a problem whoops all right huh
apex apex are you okay hello guys i think i broke apex give
me a sec i think apex was like no you cannot play octane let
me let me force quit this real fast all right so apparently
apex did not like that i try to play that i i try to say
octane just now apex was like no no no you cannot show the
world the octane stats oh my god how do i get my task
manager back here tax messenger how do i get you over here
okay guys we have a little situation okay wait what was the
guys what is the thing that force quits again what was the
keyboard shortcut guys guys what's the keyboard shirt you
know when you're like hey guys I need tech support and you
always say that thing that never fixes the game but oh alt
f4 there we go alt f I hope I don't alt f4 my fucking OBS
that'll be very unfortunate
oh no I didn't but it's not for oh my god how do i fix this
okay guys what is that but what is that uh shortcut that
lets me uh move my move my browser to another monitor sorry
i need to call tech support real quick i can't believe
picking octane fucked up my my game
what was the thing that makes it so that it'll move to my
other monitor i don't remember i don't remember what moves
my shit to the other monitor all right control alt shift
wait that doesn't sound right window shift left okay that
sounds right okay window shift left oh there you go all
right it says not responding i did it i forced quit apex oh
my god you mean to be you know to be fair the game did just
launch so like i ain't gonna blame it is it is launch day so
i'm not surprised that the game was like no all right let's
see apex yay all right i guess we're not even gonna i guess
the game doesn't want me to play octane even though like i
heard octane's powerhouse were pretty cool i think i wrote
from what i remember from the play test it was he gets like
an extra jump or some shit i don't really remember too much.
Alright, so like, I could play Rank, but then, like, I don't
really, I don't know, I don't want to get farmed right now,
because every fucking pro player out there is playing Rank
right now.
Every fucking streamer and every pro is playing.
And like, I know like, they're like 5% of the player base,
but like, it's still, they're still there.
If I get into a lobby where it's filled with like bronze
players and they're like the only pro team out there like
they're just gonna run it down and fucked me up like it's
five percent is still five percent of the lobby usually
usually they'll just run around killing everybody and i
don't want to be part of i don't want to be part of their
statistic all right i'm pretty sure i'll get the five
percent Yeah, I'm pretty sure I'm not really feeling it
unless I have a three stack Oh my god, I get to actually
show my badges I haven't seen those badges in forever Oh my
god I haven't seen those badges in so long I told you guys,
I told you guys I had them I knew it I knew I wasn't full of
code all right what is my upgrade so it takes 25% less stem
damage where the fuck I'll never get naded oh shit oh shit
okay you can tell the game just came out
oh please let me look at my inventory guys guys no you don't
understand this game this game just You don't understand.
I have not played Octane in so long.
I just know like his stuff is like fun All right zero guns.
Oh, no.
It's nice Okay, let me like I always forget to fix my
bindings.
Did he steal my loot?
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh shit I'm fucked.
I don't really have the guns right now.
Hello Oh shit you're not my teammate.
Oh No!
No!
I thought I was like...
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
That was...
Yikes.
I did not...
What the fuck?
I did not expect like two people to be there.
They can play like a team?
What do you mean?
Where's my team?
To be fair, I was...
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm already dead!
Oh my god, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Leave me alone!
Oh, no.
Oh, my God, your dog shit!
You're getting a third screen!
Look, sorry.
This was a warm-up round.
I'm not, you know, I was so...
Sorry.
That was just...
Look, if he had trouble, like, trying to kill me while I was
already down, that's on him.
That's fine.
Look, I told you!
I'm, like, the dad that just got home.
farm this is why this is why I don't play I'm not playing
rank right now I have no idea what I'm doing it's been too
long oh this guy knows what he's doing he knows the climb up
there he knows more than 90% of the player base oh oh
movement movement right there wait Tony where the fuck were
Why didn't you come and save me earlier?
You clearly know what you're doing.
But also, why the fuck are you playing Seer?
Is Seer OP now?
Also, Tony should be the one streamer.
I'm just a Tony POV streamer now.
Oh, no armor swaps.
Whoa.
Where the fuck am I?
No, pick me up.
Pick me up.
I'm so helpful.
I swear to God I'm Octane.
You know I'm useful.
No!
Stokey Bird!
Well, I don't give a fuck about Tony anymore.
There's no reasons.
Oh, shit!
Gumi, okay.
Wait, Gumi, if you're watching, let me play like five more
solos and then I'll come over.
I don't know if she's watching.
Alright, what are some...
Okay, guys.
tell me who has the best upgrades who has the best upgrades
guys who is it I'll just keep her up here alright Tony did
not want yeah they did not want to save me so they didn't
get the streamer POV now who has the best one Watson I swear
to God it's not I swear to God it's because oh wait Watson
has a thing where like Did he keep the one where, like, if
you, his, like, gas canister heals him and shit?
Did he keep that?
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
Wait, what about Bangalore?
There was one more.
Yeah!
I remember this.
That shit was so OP.
Basically, if I, if I'm in the Bangalore smoke, I reject, I
mean, I'm literally reading what it says.
I don't know why I'm through.
I don't know why I'm telling you guys.
You guys can read.
Like, yeah, like, you know, there's smoke.
my HP comes back.
So, like, I don't know if they, like, nerfed it or whatever,
but it was so fucking overpowered during the playtest.
It was so bad during the playtest.
Everyone was just playing.
Everyone was just, I remember in the playtest, it was like
my team was, like, Bangalore, Caustic, and Lifeline or
something, because it was so dumb we just healed each other
we were just self-healing each other non-stop no my
bengalore what the was the point after i'd bragged about
bengalore
i'll play pathfinder okay what do we have gain access gain
access oh shit pathfinder's fucking dog he has nothing why
do i care about like beacons or whatever
Why do I care about Intel?
I'm going to die anyway.
Can't believe it.
My game crashed.
Oh, thank God.
I guess the game.
The game was like, you don't want to play Pathfinder.
I guess you don't have to play.
Oh my God.
Apex is not what I mean!
I still want to play the game!
What the fuck, Apex!
I still want to play!
The game was like, how dare you?
I wonder if I'll still be in the lobby.
My poor guy.
It's alright, he was champion.
He can survive.
I swear to God, if I load in, I'm dead.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, this is...
I don't like being here.
Oh wait, I'm still fine.
Oh no, I have my fucking heirloom on.
Yes, back in the day I...
Sorry about the frames, it's...
It's... that's like that when you log back in.
Alright, yes, back in the day I used to spend money.
Um...
And Pathfinder heirloom has to be one of the fucking worst
heirlooms out there.
I've like realized because it's so fucking um, it's just so
annoying like it takes up too much at the screen It just
takes up too much of the screen and hate I don't like the
pathfinder heirloom All right, all right son you have your
fucking regen hp I follow you because I think you know what
you're doing
I don't know where they are.
Oh, our guy average every day.
Do you okay?
It's over there.
Ooh.
Nice.
That was fast.
Poor guy.
Yay!
You had no friends.
Poor guy.
He didn't have stun.
Cool gloves.
Thank you.
It takes up 80% of my screen.
It takes...
This is why like...
Like...
Master plus players don't have their heirlooms out anymore.
Oh my god.
Wow!
I guess...
Who cares?
I don't need Intel.
Who the fuck uses Intel?
What the fuck?
Where?
Oh shit!
Okay, there he is.
is.
I didn't know he was there.
Wait, what?
Did he come downstairs?
Where is he?
Wait, what?
I...
Oh, God.
I'm dead, dead slid.
Where the fuck are these people?
Oh!
It's okay.
I killed a TTVer.
Come on, Stein.
Reach in!
Reach in and you're sm- Oh, he's dead.
Look, I swear, all I'm saying is that if I was on Bangalore,
I would have lived.
I would have fucking lived.
Okay, all I'm going to say is that as a streamer, I blamed
my heirloom.
I feel like I should unlock all these guys real quick.
Let me...
I don't unlock again.
It's been so long.
I don't want it.
Look at this.
Unlocking.
Guys, where the fuck is the unlock button?
There's a bio now?
There's lore?
Okay, that's too much to read.
I can't.
Guys, it's been too long.
Money?
There's no way it's money now.
Even your cat's unlock.
him anymore oh right oh my god wait no what the fuck
happened it used to be so simple unlocking characters used
to be so simple when did it get so difficult for all the
dads out there you have to buy the buy button oh my gosh
there he is wait do i not have fuse why is it locked oh
challenges coming soon i'm so stupid sorry i don't i don't i
can't see i was like why is it locked i was like i thought i
bought fuse like 20 years ago i already sorry i'm i'm a
stupid dad i'm sorry i told you it's been it's been so long
since i've facts.
Alright, now.
Don't worry, guys.
It's not, it's always a warm-up until I win.
I just told you!
I told you!
Doki can't read.
Alright, here we go.
Cat, this is what I have you guys for!
You guys are supposed to backseat me.
What the fuck?
You guys had one fucking job.
Alright, this time.
Okay, okay, this.
Why would I get to play fucking Wrinkle?
I don't want to play Pathfinder.
But also, please don't crash my game again, Apex.
Please don't do it.
I can't believe it.
I wasn't paying attention.
Holy shit, it's so hot in my room.
Let me open the window real quick.
Holy shit is so high to my room.
Alright, I'm back.
Are we always going to Fragment again?
Guys.
Guys, come on.
I would love to go Fragment, but I'm on Pathfinder.
Oh my god, I actually have like trail, like not trails, but
like the animation and shit.
Oh my god, please tell me I'll find a gun.
Because I think I fucked up.
Guys, you guys have a gun I'll punch him Okay, I'm gonna
leave I don't think I have a gun Oh, wait, there's nobody
here Whoa Is there guns anywhere?
Guys Guys Oh, wait, he's 20
Oh Well, there's a lot of people here.
I'm just, I'm just gonna go down here for a little bit.
Whoa, hey guys.
Oh my god, just chill a little bit.
Gun?
Nice.
Alright.
Sorry, I had to go through finding one singular gun.
Anybody here?
Alright, nope.
Where the fuck is everybody?
it's okay i found a gun my one gun whoa hello oh my gosh
where are you hello where the fuck are people from like 500
people to zero this is that up oh oh i hear him hello
Oh, fuck, I'm stunned.
Please, it's one guy!
There's no way you get fucked over by one.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
That's okay.
We didn't get fucked over by one guy.
Oh, thank God.
Wait, there's regen now?
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Okay, I got that.
My core in.
I almost jumped into that.
That's okay.
I'm slowly...
I won't say waking up because I've been...
been awake for a long time, but my eyes are not blurring
together now.
Oh, thank God.
None of these matter.
I don't want Pathfinder's like the shittiest upgrade.
Like, who...
I'm not playing Ring.
Alright.
Oh, we need zero bullets.
That's alright.
I never needed my Mastiff, I guess.
Did I sleep?
That's a good question.
I can say that I slept three hours.
What the fuck are you doing, Bangalore?
You had regen.
Oh, we're back.
Oh, he had regen, too.
Where is he?
Wait, he's double regenning.
That's illegal.
Wait.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know where the fuck he is, but he's just regenning.
There we go.
No, he's dead!
Stop!
He's dead!
Now I'm fucking stunned!
Where is... Oh, wait, they already res.
Fuck, okay.
Where do I go?
What is that?
King Evil Harvester?
What is...
Where are these fancy buttons on my map?
Alright.
Wait.
Where the fuck is the...
That's energy.
Okay, I'm just like, where are all these fancy icons on my
map?
And I'm so confused.
Everyone's playing Seer.
I wonder what Seer has.
That's like so good.
Yay.
Oh, I could have.
Same do.
Wait!
Do I know you?
What?
Oh shit!
This is your fault, Nico!
Nico, you fucking swear to god!
Okay.
Nico, you bitch!
Oh shit.
Okay, I would help you, but like, I'm scared.
What does he mean?
The most interesting part is that he said from four years
ago.
It's like...
Oh my god.
That's like, oh gee.
Who the fuck is he?
Ah, fuck.
I'm dead.
Doesn't matter.
Please cover me.
Please, I'm just a harm.
Harmless Pathfinder.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm okay.
He's not even a dragon because he literally said from four
years ago.
That's when you're like super...
Oh, fuck.
That's when you know you're super OG.
I swear to God.
Alright.
Please.
Please stop.
I haven't shot my gun.
Man, I wish I can regen and smoke.
Alright.
I need HP, though.
Oh my god, I have no scope for this.
Please.
Please, I'm begging you.
Give me anything.
all right we gotta help nico nico we're coming over nico
don't worry where is he
oh my god i cannot just scope stuff i forgot how fucking
shitty it is so do iron sight pap i'm gonna thirst him iron
sight fucking flatline is so hard i don't want to grapple
because i can see there's a path finder on the right.
Fuck it.
What's gonna happen?
Me dying?
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
Please thirst him.
For the sake of my HP.
Oh, why did you thirst him?
No, I wanted an armor swap.
No!
Why?
I wanted a fucking armor swap.
Please!
They're coming!
No!
Okay.
There's no way he knows I'm here healing.
There's no fucking way.
They'll kill my teammates first before they kill me, and
that's okay.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
Oh, thank God.
There's, like, actual...
There's a fucking scope now.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
What can I do?
Take 25% less damage.
down i mean that seems like the only good thing from
pathfinder that seems like the other one like sucks when
will i ever need to use my zip and like not take damage all
right nice oh hey yes that's what i like to see who the fuck
is nico i like how he never even told me who he is I'm just
like who who are you have I played with this guy before a
sacrifice I'm exactly as long as the streamer is alive they
get to you know get a little bit of you know Nico there gets
a little bit of the the high life you know they need me
alive they need the streamer cam Oh my god, it's the Nico.
You guys don't even know who he is.
The only reason why you're cheering for him is because he,
like, recognized me.
So you can self-insert yourself in him.
How the fuck are people?
Oh my god, there's five squads left.
Like how he's never...
Did he say anything?
He hasn't even...
He's never responded.
There's nobody here.
I feel like we have to go to the zone anyway.
Oh, wait.
Let me... No!
That's an Eva 8?
Really?
Come on, guys.
We gotta go.
But I don't want to be the first one over.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Oh, it's over there.
Alright.
Let's go.
No!
I couldn't get the Eva 8.
Alright, where the fuck are they?
Oh shit, there they are.
I feel like I'm gonna die from this.
Nico, go in.
Die for me.
Die for Joachimburg from four years ago.
Wait, where are they?
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Hey.
Oh.
I mean, okay.
there's no way he went for me what fucking crazy i i was
like you're gonna peak that still i did not expect him to
come back i didn't expect that i thought he was you know i
thought after your one hp you know you're like maybe i
should heal
i can't believe he came back for me it's okay we have nico
from four years ago nico collab i wonder if nico's like on
my fucking friends list i like played whoa oh shit nico
thank you thank you all right nice oh my god it's the
fireball the fireball is scary oh shit nico did it oh my god
nico Nico!
What?
He killed everybody.
I like added so many people on this account as long as
they're fucking cracked.
I was like, yes.
Nico's got me.
Oh my god, Nico!
Nico!
Thank you.
Nico's got me again.
Oh my god, I can win by doing absolutely nothing.
watch this Nico go he's like a Pokemon go Nico oh shit maybe
I should help Nico though hello oh my god whoops whoa wait
there's a teammate right here that's helping me guys he's so
low I swear to God no shoot him he's literally right there
it's so easy to shoot what the fuck is loot dispenser okay
bye no lit dispenser help him guys I think I don't think
Nico's guys gonna get you get this wait unless no you're so
close okay that was my fault I fucking aggroed so hard I was
like I'm sorry I got a little bit too excited I forgot I was
supposed to not do anything that was my bad that was my bad
I was like oh yeah I was like wait maybe I can shoot my gun
and that was my bad I forgot I forgot I was supposed to let
other people for me.
Oh my god.
But also, what the fuck was Luda Spencer doing?
Where was he?
How could this happen to Nico from four years ago?
Okay, let me...
Actually, I'm curious.
Do I actually have Nico on my friends list?
Let's see.
Okay.
No, I do not.
Alright, okay.
I don't know who the fuck Nico is.
But I...
I have I've noted who Nico is But he is not in my friend's
list Alright, at least that I know Who the fuck is he?
Apparently he's from four years ago But who?
Truly a mystery I can't add him It doesn't show He has the
thing where He doesn't want randoms to add him He doesn't
want like Chitters like me to add This guy Yeah Yeah
all right sorry i didn't my audio check guy was like hey you
can turn down your volume your game volume a little bit all
right this is the last game we're gonna invite gumio over to
play i just wanted to explore manio oh my god rave he's
alleged he is nico from four years he's he only he appears
once every 40 years.
I'll never see him again.
The only time we can ever see Nico from four years ago is to
wait another four years.
We will never forget you, Nico.
Until we meet again in four years.
Until we mark this calendar.
2028.
Whatever date it is today.
Nico again.
Best of He's Nico from GTA.
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit, TikTok.
Okay guys.
I'll tell you guys.
I was gonna like save.
I was gonna reveal it later.
But you guys know how I got a play button.
So like apparently you could put any name on there.
You can put any name on the play button So I put Doki Bird
FPS V2 You can put any You can put any Oh shit Okay Please
Leave me Oh my Swear to God Give me one gun I swear the guy
I just want one gun okay gun oh thank god nice okay I got a
gun oh my god Mario where oh my god holy shit castrape oh
it's everywhere they're everywhere all right I didn't
realize There were three people there.
Alright, anyway.
Sorry.
That was unlucky.
Look, if I had a gun.
Okay, Gumi, one more game.
One more game, Gumi.
One more game.
Look, it's because we had Mario.
Alright.
Oh, hey, it's this TikTok guy.
It's TikTok guy again.
Look, it's because, like, I just didn't have a gun.
What can I say?
Is that actually OP?
What the fuck does Seer have?
Increased passive, faster movement.
Wait, I want to know.
Increased throw range.
Increased tactical scan.
I mean, that's alright.
Is it really that OP?
Wait, is that Nico?
No, okay.
God damn it.
I thought you guys actually baited me.
I was like, did I actually forgot how to read and missed out
on Nico?
Oh my god, Happy Tree.
He has a TSM banner.
And he has a 4K damage badge.
to be fair they like nerf controller players hard by taking
up all taking all the configs out thank fucking god the
moment they banned all configs like it was like so
noticeable when like games suddenly got like incredibly
easier because like all the controller players didn't have
movement anymore it actually got so much easier to play
Thank fucking god.
It's crazy.
Let's see in that video.
But all the comics people can use on Roller.
It's actually crazy.
Where's Nico?
He's dead.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, there's a gun.
Would Doki get a gun?
I did.
Nice.
Yuki got a gun.
Whoa!
Again, already.
What?
Where are they?
She got shot at, but where?
Where?
I swear to everybody is everywhere but near me.
Oh, there.
Oh.
I heard, like, uh...
I heard a Watson fence near me, so I'm gonna slowly heal up
in my smoke.
Yay, self-heal.
Where?
Oh, Seer, please!
Seer!
It's fine, we're fine.
We gotta help.
We gotta help him.
Nice.
I'm gonna take that armor swap real fast.
Oh, no.
I swear to God, I'm forever lost in this area.
Oh, new team.
Whoa.
New team.
Let me block this real fast.
No, Happy Tree!
Don't worry, I got you!
There's no ways coming over!
There's literally a nade.
It's okay.
Please.
Seer, come closer.
Seer!
Crawl to me!
Okay, it's fine.
I didn't need you to crawl to me anyway.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
How the fuck did he have...
Oh!
Are you serious?
How did he have all?
I didn't have all!
Oh, yeah.
god all right wait he was oh yeah because he had all i was
gonna be like what i didn't even get his arm i didn't even
get his hp all right okay now now we can do it all right let
me call gumi let me call gumi shit nico shit okay who the
hey why are you screaming i said i got i got i got nico from
four years ago joining us.
What the fuck?
I don't know who he is.
Yes, I just kept hearing you say, who the fuck is this dude?
I'm playing Cookie Run on the side.
He's like the legend.
He's the legend.
Nico.
I invite me, and I'll invite Nico.
I think he'll...
I'm not like you're making shit up, I'll be honest.
No, no, I swear to God.
Okay, okay, where is he?
I'm pretty sure he'll ditch his game for us.
nature wait where the is he he's not even in my wait did you
log off doesn't exist he doesn't exist he's not real i swear
to god i love him i swear to god i there he is nico okay all
right all right all right i'm gonna see if he'll ditch his
game for us i'm waiting i invited him if he's like a true a
true homie he'll ditch his cane for us oh my god who the
fuck is he wait who are you
from for you who is this guy bro but he's crackville who are
you nico from we played it Oh shit.
Nico, four years ago.
He's making shit up.
He's like, yeah, I went to your high school.
Bro, no, okay.
Oh shit, I started.
Whoops, I forgot.
No, don't there's no way.
Oh, wait, I accidentally toggled.
Sorry, I can't stop my emotions right now.
I'm trying to reset my emotions right now Why was this okay?
I got it.
Sorry.
I don't want to be jump master.
It's okay.
Nico Nico be god damn it This is why we're inviting you Nico
Nico
Jump or kick
That's what we've done Yeah, that's what he's done, bitch
Jumper cake Yeah Oh my god, bro, okay, to be fair, I played
with a lot of people Excuse me Oh no, what's going on?
Nothing, I'm okay Comey!
Comey!
Stop!
Just die!
So I can press you!
Nico got you.
Nico got the gun!
I literally got you!
Okay, that's not my fault.
Nico got literally killed him for us.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry, Nico's got us.
I literally have one gun.
There's more people.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's fine.
Woo, it's not fine.
I cracked him.
I literally cracked him, please.
Nico, yes!
Oh, Nico!
Clutcher kick.
Clutcher kick, clutcher kick.
Oh, my God.
He has an arrow in him.
I don't have one of those.
Oh, my God.
He can talk.
He's not just a fucking apex bot.
He actually can speak.
He can actually...
He can actually talk.
Wait.
He's kind of moving like a Fortnite bot right now.
I like it.
Wait.
Okay.
I think he has to be mouse and keyboard.
I remember because I only play with M&K players in season
three.
Because controller players never existed back then.
Oh.
Go, Nico.
Oh, my God.
He grabbed me.
Leave.
Just leave.
Nico.
Go.
Put your heirloom away, man!
Look, he earned that fair and square, Gumi.
Oh, no!
Nico!
It's okay.
He's fine.
It's Nico time.
It's me.
Hey, this is really cool.
You know what?
It's good thing we died.
Now we can actually watch real gameplay.
Yeah, now I'm opening up Kingdom Kingdom again.
now this is like actual real gameplay someone that can
actually play apex wait i don't know when was the last time
i played thanks for the thanks for the free thanks for the
free entertainment nico look oh my god nice then nico pov i
swear you guys but my chat's like i hope you i hope you i
hope you die again in game so you can watch nico So we did
not...
I clearly still only have...
I clearly still only have like...
Whoa!
I'm scared!
Okay, I'm so scared!
I'm fucked.
Nico, I cracked one.
Get them all.
Okay, the thing is...
I don't think Nico is getting them.
No, Keith, there's two...
There's...
They have literally...
They're literally flying!
Um...
purple armor um um wait it's okay it's okay it's okay i'll
be come back i'll come back i swear to god i'll come back i
swear to god yeah yeah yeah yeah i swear to god i'll come
back i swear to god i'll come back don't worry you me i
swear what are they gonna do like camp your bodies until you
die there's no way maybe maybe no no no no no no no there's
no way to get that cringe no no no no no know right there's
no way they want to do that to us we're streamers
right all right all right um okay you guys can't say clutch
or kick to me because i'm literally streaming yeah all right
are they there who the fuck are you asking i don't know you
guys might have better eyes than me looking from your eyes!
Yeah, but you guys might look better!
Oh, nice.
Okay, there you go.
See, I told you guys.
I told you.
Alright, I do have better eyes.
Oh, don't fear you!
What?
Up!
Down near you!
Okay, okay, it's fine.
Oh, I accidentally...
There we go.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
It's fine.
I don't know why the fuck the crypto was there.
Yeah, that was...
I don't know why I didn't...
Alright, it's fine, we're fine.
Hey, what is that little yellow...
I am.
Oh, it's an armor upgrade.
I swear to God, I hurt the fucking crypto again!
Leave me alone!
Holy shit!
What do you mean?
Oh my god, I dead slid.
I dead slid.
I panicked.
Okay, that way.
My screamer.
I'm panicking.
I'm literally panicking.
I didn't get enough sleep to be doing this.
Hi.
My wife Okay,
they're fighting.
Okay nice.
Okay planned.
All right.
I it's like they're so confused at me nating myself that
they just They stopped chasing me.
Am I singing calm me down?
I know.
Yeah.
We'll say that What yeah.
Beautiful saying Gumi Beautiful singing All right, don't
worry We're fine.
Oh, yeah.
We're fine.
See?
I calmed down.
See, look at that.
I just needed a res you guys.
And it's just like nothing bad happened.
Look at that.
Everything's fine.
What did they do to the tree yard?
Boy, it looks the same.
That's literally what it looked like last season.
No, what happened to the float?
different it's just literally this looks different they made
it purple looks the same okay okay gumi you haven't played
apex in a while dude i feel like a boomer you literally
haven't played apex in so long it's literally the same the
same chain right this would cost 25 cents oh i need to make
my bad oh yeah you can only use replicator like once now
what yeah see look we're all okay I'm still I'm still uh
with the shittiest guns possible right now with zero
attachments and that's okay nice I upgraded what I upgraded
don't worry I upgraded our shit oh nice there's like fights
near us on the other side no I'm good I'm good it's okay we
have nico i bet you nico's gonna get my our first win today
oh shit nico might be dead oh nico wake up nico wake up
samurai that's my old i'm gonna hurt myself it's my old it's
my old it's my old it's my old you're fine you're fine i hit
nothing
What's going on?
Where are they?
Can you ping it?
I don't see nothing.
I'm in a few.
I'll see.
Where are they?
Oh.
Whoa.
Splash.
Got him.
Got Nicholas.
Oh.
Yeah, I got him.
His teammates over there.
Tracked him.
He splashed.
Stupid.
Nice.
Yeah!
Look at us go.
We're gaming.
We're better.
So much better.
Look at that.
Are you okay?
Let me look at sound check guy to see if you're not bursting
people's eardrum.
Hey, okay, he's like everything is good.
Okay, I just have to...
Gumi!
Stop!
Stop getting shot at!
Gumi!
I'm like oh my god I hit nothing that's awkward I didn't hit
a single thing where are you fucking sure gonna get up how
are we gonna win oh they're coming up they're coming up oh I
can't see I can't see for you I can't cover you wait they
have red armor wait they're gamers wait we lost their actual
carry what the fuck do we do by the way I I died Gumi I
can't help you oh you're dead too wait you're still alive I
thought you're dead are
you are you okay are you okay Why didn't you why didn't you
cue into it?
They went up my ass!
You could have ran!
I abandoned you!
What do you mean I abandoned you?
What?
You couldn't have done that for me!
Yes, you could have done that!
I abandoned you and came back!
That's okay.
No, we all know it's Nico's fault.
Yeah, fuck you, Niko.
you, Nico.
How dare you?
Why are you in our three stack if you're not clutch and if
you're not clutching?
Wait!
We're three stacking.
We should play rank.
We're all... You literally...
Okay.
We can be farming the bronze players.
The real bronze... It's like...
Okay, look.
Okay, hear me out.
The game came out.
The new season patch came out like 11-12-1-2.
Four hours ago.
Preds shouldn't be in anymore at that point.
They should have ranked out of it.
I have people from DSG and they're ranking up right now,
surely.
Which means all the Preds are playing right now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're all playing, but they've been playing for four
hours.
If they play for four hours, what if they keep inting each
other and they're all still bronze?
There's no way!
Then they're not, then they're dog shit.
Oh.
Okay, I didn't say it.
Okay.
I'm saying if they're still if they're still in bronze Not
even bronze.
They start off at rookie.
We start at rookie because everyone starts at one point Look
if I'm saying if it by in four hours you're still you're
still in rookie and you're you're professional player that
gets paid to play Apex legends that it's not it's not an us
problem.
It's a you problem It's okay.
We have Nico Nico, you hand that shit over.
What the fuck, Nico?
Don't worry, we say one thing.
Clutch or jump?
Oh, wait, wait.
Kick or jump?
There you go.
Oh, my God.
Jump for your game.
Nico, that's not it.
That's not it.
That's it.
Oh.
All right, here we go.
Isn't it great?
Isn't it great when we have a carry?
I see people here with us, Stokey.
It's okay.
We have a carry.
He's some guy used to play in season three.
Stokey, they're gonna beat his ass.
They're beating his ass.
It's okay.
As long as not us, it's okay.
Oh, shit.
Maybe we should help him.
Coming over.
Oh shit, Diko.
No!
Oh, he's got him.
Diko, don't die, because I need ammo.
Don't die, because I... Damn.
Wait, where's his... Where's the third?
Where the fuck is the third player?
There's fuckers!
Oh shit!
Oh, go me!
What happened?
It's the... It's the fucker!
Oh, where?
Oh, I was you.
Don't worry, Niko's got this.
See?
Yeah!
We killed a TTV here!
And New York!
Oh!
There's a new team.
Blocking this?
Ow!
Oh, I can't see anything.
Nice.
There's a teammate.
Where?
Whoa, shit, here!
Okay.
Easy.
So easy.
Oh, it's like the...
new armor swap but instead of like swapping the armor it
just fills up your armor oh hey we killed everybody here see
what were you worried about yeah i have two kp i'm a big kid
now yeah yeah but what's your damage huh oh yeah i have
seven oh shit i have seven hundred and five what the yeah
now you're making shut up what me no wait wait wait sorry
sorry i verbal typo i mean sorry i had a mini stroke right
now um i'm at 130.
oh hey everyone makes a pay yeah yeah whoa gold backpack oh
i thought i was like wondering what he's shooting at uh all
right let me you get rid of a battery whoa oh i heard like
that i heard the oh my god nico are you getting fucked in hd
rtx on it's a two team of two i think it's three i cracked
this year though i only saw two of my little passive cracked
here again all right do it come go go go go go go i believe
in you i'm here i'm here go go go go go go go go i share how
my teammates are here with I hope so too.
Wait, where's the seer?
Oh, I'm me.
Yo!
Nice.
I feel like it's so cluttered, though.
Like, all the words on my screen.
Yeah.
I don't know how to read, so it's a... See nearby ordinance.
I don't need names.
It just feels so cluttered.
This Nico single.
Alright, Who wants me to ask?
Guys, we don't even know how old he is, man.
Hold on, wait a minute.
First off, we gotta ask how old Nico is.
First off.
Why is that?
Before we ask if anybody is single, we need to know how old
Nico is.
Guys.
So remember, Remember, the order of the questions matter,
guys.
The order of the questions.
Guys, I know Valentine's is tomorrow, but remember.
Order of questions.
Order of operations.
At least four.
A truth.
Nico, that's the fucking child prodigy thing.
Apex in the fucking womb.
Fucking genius.
Oh my god.
He's like that 10-year-old Apex prodigy.
Pred player or some shit.
You know, there's like...
What's his name?
Liffordson or whatever.
What?
There's like this controller or prodigy Pred player who's
like this like 10-year-old kid.
And his like...
His dad runs his like...
Oh, there's people on us, I think.
His dad runs his like Twitch and everything.
And all he does is just play Apex while his dad controls
his...
Whoa!
You go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go me, go, go, go, go.
Oh, go where?
Here!
See?
Oh, we got help, Nico.
Wait, they're resing.
Where is he?
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is dead.
I helped.
Yeah, you were there.
What?
I threw maids, man.
Yeah, you were there.
Yeah, I was there.
Sometimes I wonder if you're okay.
And then...
That was a fucking answer!
Alright.
Ooh, I can heal myself in smoke.
Oh my god, we're gonna get our first win.
I believe in us.
Don't say that.
We're gonna get our first win.
Wait, did I grab my shield back?
Oh my god, it cramps right away?
Yeah, that's the new update, but you only craft once.
YOLO.
movies as insane as ever that's why she's my friend yeah i
need someone to make me feel normal
next to you most normal i heard some It's okay.
Okay.
And Nanya.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so if we don't look at them, they don't exist, right?
Yeah.
Ken only has a good day if Barbie looks at him.
And they're all Ken's.
Even you, Niko.
Whoa, Niko's just a Ken.
That's fucked up.
He can be a Barbie if he wants.
Not if he keeps relinquishing Jump Master.
Ooh, that's true.
You make Apex look so easy.
He thinks I have a Nico.
Nico, I'll sue something.
Go!
Kill everyone.
Akumi and I chill.
Well, we just chill.
Yeah, they're over here.
Oh, shit.
Okay, almost fell.
Oh, rata, rata, rata.
Uh, how do I climb back up?
There you go.
Go, Akumi.
Go.
Oh, wait, no, he's all the way up there.
Bastard!
Oh, wait, they changed this a little bit.
Whoa!
Knocked one.
Oh, right here.
Oh, cracked him.
Oh, he's grappling away.
Oh, my God, that poor guy.
I just saw him get executed.
Where the fuck is this Pathfinder, though?
Above?
He's above me?
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, he scared the shit out of me.
He's like above me?
There's people behind me.
It's fine.
Whoa.
Not fine, not fine.
Oh, where are you?
Um, there's a guy right here where I'm pinging.
What the fuck was he doing?
Watch there.
Another team is fighting in front of us.
There's a new team.
My Oshiniko is not single.
Day ruined.
No!
Oh, I got a heal now.
It's okay.
I have self-heal.
I'm needing.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm not.
but i knocked one two oh oh oh oh i'm shielding i'm
shielding oh they tried it oh they're coming we got no we're
so close oh my god what is this you ruined all of our days
no we just didn't three stack hard enough clearly we did not
three stack hard i knocked mine oh like we all right mate
don't worry we'll get first place in rank a buddha us up.
Lock us in.
Okay.
Do it.
Rookie.
Wait, is he rookie as well?
Okay, thank God.
Lock us in.
Alright, is Kano it's still strong in rank?
I don't know what's meta.
I don't know what's meta either.
I just like Vantage.
Yeah, I know.
Okay, okay.
I know.
It's okay.
All the It's ranked out a rookie.
There's no way.
There's no way we're that unlucky.
We're gonna be the ones that, like, bone rush all the
players.
Yes.
Conduit got nerfed?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I guess I'll play Bangalore.
Apparently Conduit's nerfed.
Wait, okay.
How about Seer?
I know I'll play Seer.
Actually, no, I should play Bangalore.
And that's my comfort pick.
No, there's no way they had four hours if they can't get a
out of rookie in four hours then why the fuck are they pred
yeah just think about it it literally takes like five games
to get a rookie if you're in pred if you're a pred player
all right nico take us home nico nico nico come on Haha, I
rejoined at the right time.
We're dropping Among Us.
Don't worry, I believe in us.
You played Among Us.
You were an Among Us player.
Where'd you're professional?
You were in all those streamer lobbies.
Yeah, that's right.
That's Miss Gumiho, the Among Us player.
Yeah.
Yeah, she was in all those Among Us lobbies.
Yeah, I know her.
Oh, it's your ripple tank!
Yeah.
She was like, uh-huh.
Yeah, I know her.
She was like in the disguise toast lobbies.
She was a pretty big deal.
Rookie!
Wait, were you actually in the toast lobbies though?
Actually, I remember that.
Oh man, I was in the hafu lobbies.
Oh, you're in the hafu lobbies.
Yeah, she was in the hafu lobbies.
She's a pretty big deal.
Knox, one?
There's a teammate though.
teammates oh shit i told you look they're all rookies
because they all start rookies hey purple backpack here oh
nice better take it before nico does i pinged it he respects
pings right where's their third though oh no oh fuck they're
not a third player
Are they run already?
Please, I have zero kills.
I don't want to join in.
Hello?
I guess they ran off.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, I heard someone.
Wait, where?
No!
I couldn't farm.
You should, like, let me tap it.
Well, that wasn't me who did not.
Fucking Nico.
No.
We should kick him out.
Yeah.
I think so too.
Lesson number one.
Always let us tap.
Hold on, don't say it like that.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
I didn't sign up for this.
I...
all right okay nico igls igl us igl us nico i'm getting
sleepy igl us tell us what to do wait he's leaving wait digi
doesn't go to r9 anymore it goes to shotgun and what
You don't use Digi on R9 on like R9 anymore.
Where the fuck does that happen?
On SMGs.
Wow!
Bow!
Nico, don't call yourself the mama duck ever again.
Yeah, that's cringe.
That's pretty fucking cringe.
That's fucking cringe, man.
I'm cringing right now.
I'm cringing.
God, typically apex player.
Where?
I guess in no direction.
You guys sound like a...
I wish we can melee boost.
I missed that.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you...
Okay.
You punched a shit out of me.
I...
Most of...
What?
I mean, if you consented...
Um...
I mean, that's what you're into.
Okay.
Oh!
You remember you have...
white armor whoa
um wait there's another team over there I'm busy wait I'm
scaled now they're white all white armor come on all this
come on my old
they're like up on the rock I cracked them one right here
all dead nice there's more fighting behind us all right i'm
just pushing up then oh shit look at all these boxes nice
i'm gonna grab this real fast will you guys be okay i'm
looting i'm looting this is important
this is more important oh shit nico okay i'm coming over all
right don't worry I should Level up myself Whoa Needle if
you don't get him Why I oughta?
There you go Is there anything, buddy?
Is there people in front of us?
Because I'm looting?
I'm looting?
No Nice Nico Are you not res?
What is going on?
What's going on?
Nothing.
Nice.
Look at that.
I contributed.
I'm going to push forward and see there's people in front of
us.
Oh.
There was a logo up there.
Did they use it?
Yeah.
Wait, they did.
They should come down to us.
Okay, let's just wait.
Right?
Yeah, they're here.
Come on, Loba.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
Where's his teammate?
Where's your teammate, Loba?
It's your teammate, Loba.
It's your teammate, too.
White armor and blue armor.
There he is.
Tract him?
There.
Good for 50?
Nice.
Oh, hello, rookie.
I want to stay in this Elo forever.
Isn't that great?
Ew, you know.
Don't even have a redeploy.
I have a...
I hear fighting north side.
North side?
Okay, I'm going away.
over.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Wait, someone has a Kramer.
Yeah, they're fighting hard.
They're fighting hard.
On me?
Flesh?
Down?
Left side?
Oh, careful of the fucking ball of fire.
Wait.
What?
Oh, nice.
Flesh?
I'm worried.
I think they're gonna res my kill.
Pushing up?
Hit 63.
Flesh?
In front of me?
I'm pushing.
There's an alt in front of me so I can't push.
Careful, Gumi.
You're by yourself.
Yeah, I'm chilling.
Flesh?
They have a bow check or something.
You're fine.
You're dead.
Off the river there's him.
Nice.
Where's the...
Oh.
Oniko.
Dead.
Okay, there was another team over there earlier.
Yeah, I think they resmed my kill.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure they resed it.
Let's see.
Oh, I can regen on my heals now.
Yippee!
And loot.
I love loot.
Oh, in front of me?
In front of me?
And they're fighting to my left.
Yeah, yeah.
Right here.
I'm pushing.
I'm madding.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's one!
I fucked up my aim there.
There's a guy behind this box, that's low.
Or he healed.
There's a guy right behind this too.
Oh nice, they got the key.
It's a team of blue armors.
Yeah, it's just a seer.
There's a team on my right as well.
You should be fine.
Yeah.
I think we have to go to zone soon though.
You know what?
Fuck you.
Are they resing?
All right, I'm finishing.
Nice.
I made a statement.
I think there's like people in front of me though.
I'm right behind you.
Yeah, there's a res.
Res in front.
Whoa!
Helting?
Fishing this?
This is like nonstop.
fighting.
I love this, Evo.
Oh, I'm going to ult it myself.
Can't push anymore.
Yeah, I saw that.
I was a bit crazy about it, but I didn't.
Look, I forgot.
But they just ran.
Look, they're just running away.
Not there.
Do we have redeploy?
Redeploy.
I spelled redeploy wrong.
Now.
Where's our redeploy?
Nico, you literally have redeploy!
Oh my god.
God damn it, Nico.
Okay.
We need a zone, though.
Yeah, they went up.
Yeah, they have high ground.
I'm pushing up.
Nico, it's all your fault.
This is all your fault.
I said redeploy.
I said one simple word.
Okay.
He did say that.
I heard it.
Yeah, I heard it too.
We all heard it.
Yep, we all heard it.
I'm going to take the bonsai platform.
Deploy or kick.
Oh, there he is.
There's his teammate, though.
What's your real ring?
Mr. Mr. Loba.
Can I farm you?
Let's see.
Go, Nico.
Tell us what their rank is if they can shoot you.
Won't know if they can aim.
I'm gonna go to the right.
Knock.
What the fuck are they doing?
Flesh?
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, goodbye!
There he is.
He's gone.
It's fine.
That is not my ult, by the way, so...
That could be a different team's ult.
I need ammo, actually.
No land energy?
Fuck.
Where's the other guy we killed?
Uh, I can drop you 16 energy right here.
Yeah, I need it.
There's a new team.
In front of us.
Now you're not fighting.
Yeah, you're literally right in front.
Hard fighting?
Oh!
Sorry, I don't know if it's 40.
I made up the number.
Okay.
Oh, look him go!
Flesh.
Huh?
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, I'm gonna fucking head to zone.
Oh, hey!
What's that?
Do you even get it?
No.
Alright, I'll take you.
I was running out anyway.
I was running out of ammo.
Might as well.
Wait, what?
He needed us.
Who is it?
Oh, there was another scan.
Wasn't you or Nico that punched me?
Look where I am.
Like, what do you think?
I'm so far from you.
We need to go to his own, though.
I am heading down.
Mr. Burns.
zone.
Super Nico.
Let me...
No!
If he was a real gamer, he would have a fucking bottle.
That's called the streamer life.
What would be great about...
Next merch idea.
The gamer bottle.
Ew.
Where the fuck are there's still like three teams left where
are they Yeah go for it What do you mean no if he was if he
is a real gamer?
He'd hold it in or get a bottle Only real gamers now oh wait
there's two next to us there's two above us
They just rest.
Where the fuck is the...
No, there's two, like, right next to us somewhere.
Wait, that's a...
There's one right above me.
Are they, like...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I'm ripping!
Tracked him?
Okay.
One bell?
Oh, that's guy.
He's, like, literally one guy.
Oh, army?
Tracked him?
Cracked the bloodhound in front of us.
Cracked him?
Not?
He's cracked.
Okay, but I'm not letting this guy rise, though.
Let, uh, crack 10-5?
Is this the last guy?
Yeah!
I told you!
We won in New York!
I told you, rank is so easy to farm.
These are farm to fucking pause Told you so easy What the
fuck?
Now what happened my screen Oh, yeah, nice.
I'm such a triple wasn't that epic.
Oh, yeah, the triple take is nerfed as hell Dude, you just
don't want me to play this game Oh my god, how much do we,
how many points did we gain there?
425, I told you, it literally takes like four to five games
for a prayer to like get out of rookie.
For literally rookie three.
Oh.
It was a legendary frame.
It was, it literally took us like one game to get to rookie,
almost to rookie two.
Please, I want to stay in rookie forever.
Please, it's so fun.
It's like, OG, OG pubs.
It's okay.
He can, like, speed ruin.
He's a man.
It's alright.
Look at that!
Gumi, we did it!
We won!
Are you proud of us?
Yeah, I'm proud.
We did it.
Yay!
Yippee!
We did it!
Yay!
Are you gonna let Nico join the voice chat girls only?
No men allow Yeah, my game crashed
Guys, I don't think my game can keep my only the game likes
that I I restricted the voice chat
Let me put my game back up it's okay it's okay I'm coming
back I'm coming literally not dropping us I think he also I
know I think no he's using the bathroom right now is I can't
leave or else it I'm back I'm back I'm back the game was
like rise up men Man, don't let her talk about us like this.
Oh, there's someone!
It's okay, just kill him!
What are you afraid of?
Oh, goomy!
Goomy, goomy, what happened?
Goomy, what happened?
What do you mean?
I think these guys are gamers now.
They're not regular rookies.
They're not regular rookie players.
Oh, I don't have frames right now.
Woo!
Okay, now I have frames.
Whoa!
There's another...
There's another team!
That's why we don't let Niko.
This is why this is Niko's fault.
Yeah.
I blame Niko.
Yeah, Niko just got owned.
What's wrong with you, Niko?
Yeah, what's wrong with you?
Anyways.
What's wrong with you, Niko?
This is your fault.
Oh!
Whoa, he has teammates?
teammates, I wouldn't have died.
My rookie boys!
I'm good.
I'm good now.
Okay.
Look, we blame Nico, right?
Yep.
Yeah.
He doesn't have a voice so we can blame him.
No, there's no MMR.
We just landed somewhere that had actual good players.
Oh wait, we're on trios.
Wait, were we not in rank?
Were we?
No, we were.
No!
Gumi!
Gumi, take us back!
Take us back to rank.
It was so much more fun.
My bad.
I went to go get a Shumai.
Oh, nice.
How is it?
It's cold.
Nice.
Not nice.
Does this bring Miko?
Let him speak.
Dude, I don't want to hear it.
If he wanted to talk to us, he could have used the open VC
in the game.
Right?
What's stopping him from using that?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Even if Nico were here, do you think he could talk over us?
Do you hear us?
True, true.
I don't even hear my own thoughts.
Let Nico speak.
This Gumiho, the real Gumiho, yes, the among us Minecraft
Gumiho.
Valorant.
Hey, can we change how you introduce me?
Oh, sorry.
The Minecrafters.
Is that...
No!
Mike and Crash.
Why are you fucking kidding?
I...
What?
Oh, I guess we gotta swap to Mel right now.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Give me a sec.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, here we go.
Nice, okay.
All right, for some reason it's windowed now.
That's not great.
I don't know why I keep crashing.
See, fair, every Apex update fucks up the PC one way or
another.
Okay, just don't let me die.
Please.
Nicholas landing us.
There's one squad.
Okay, let me make sure we're not windowed.
Alright, I'm good.
I'm gonna have shit frames for one second.
Uh...
We don't have people contesting us now.
No, they're far.
Oh hey.
Want that?
A shitty gun?
She's special to me!
Yeah, but it's old and shitty now.
It's like you're talking about me to that's why you love the
triple take right hey hey hey hey hey hey hey what the hey
you taught me everything i know about looted what the hey i
can kick you out right now but i won't do it oh yeah you
think i won't i'll go take a nap you think i won't You think
I want
Yeah, that's right.
Don't test me.
I'll take Nico away from you right now Girl, I don't want
him
What the fuck don't say that in front of chat?
Dude, you shouldn't even ask what his age was Dude, like, is
he?
You can't blame me on that you can't They made me up.
You raised them.
Look, I wouldn't say raised them.
It's more like, I, like, you know, I gave them an iPad and
then let them go wild.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you know, they're iPad kids.
Oh, shit!
Nico!
Okay, okay, that...
I was not paying attention.
I was not...
Did he fly?
What?
Hey, I'm getting sniped.
Oh.
Sorry.
I slid.
That was...
Oh, wait.
I didn't go take you a rope.
No, no, no, no.
That's fine.
Nico's got this.
Please, Nico, don't die.
Coco melon, Coco melon.
Give me iPad.
Coco melon.
Flush.
It's fine.
We got...
Nico's got...
Nico literally 1v2.
Let's go.
I literally clashed one and did 50.
Flush it up.
That's fine.
He 1v2.
Well, well, my loot now.
Look, see?
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, that's another squad.
Doki, give me Cocomelon!
What?
No, that's gonna damage your brain!
That's gonna damage your cognitive!
Cocomelon!
Don't you know that?
Cocomelon fucks up your cognitive and brain!
Also, I got one.
I got rusty loot, whatever is new.
48 flesh on me there's like two teams here what the fuck I
think they like res'd there's like still two teams though
does anyone have energy they raid portal oh okay there's the
second team then oh my god he's fucking crazy I'm just gonna
grab this what Oh nice, okay.
I couldn't get him.
Wait, he's gonna take the zip?
I think he's gonna get it.
Wait, wait, in front of me?
Bloodhound scan?
Behind?
Right here?
Flesh?
Nice.
I'm shielding.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm bliffy!
It's fine!
Dead, dead, dead!
One more, one more, one more!
new team Jesus Christ how many teams are there I need a
shield too oh there's another team behind me okay I'm
leaving I'm sorry I'm gonna heal here there's
way too many people there's people on me all three teams i
was crazy i'm trying to figure out where if they're fighting
each other now nico's fighting nico no you're crazy don't be
a hero
nico no oh my god he is actually being here right oh he's
dead are you safe are you safe nico please speak to me i'm
looking nico is safe No, he's not safe.
Not anymore.
You liar!
You fucking liar!
He literally was!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I can't believe you lied to me like that, Gumi.
Wait.
Rink, rink, rink.
Um, that was definitely not my fault.
Oh my god, he has a voice!
Hey!
What are you doing?
What's the- What are you doing, Nico?
Where's the- Oh my god, you like whipped it.
What the fuck?
Like...
The way he said sorry
Nico What do you mean get ready for a crash?
I didn't do anything this time That was gooey He will not be
silenced Oh my god I think you're trying to like down fast
All right, Gumi, where are we going?
Huh?
Don't make me say it, Nico.
That's right.
Nico, that's why you haven't been promoted in four years.
Whoa!
You're still old.
Holy Nico.
Wait, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
What else would he be called?
What would he be called if it wasn't Nico?
There's a guy in the center.
There's a guy.
Wait, where the fuck are you?
Like, main?
Like, oh, Nico and I are underground.
Like, what the rat?
uh there's a team right here i can what where are they oh
okay where's this teammate oh shit hello will you guys be
fine nice yeah i'm showing we're fine it might be low health
but that's whatever see if i care see we're okay nothing to
worry about nico is best girl wait then what's goomy then
wait a second come on guys don't don't hold yourself hello
what would goomy be guys rambling side chicks
Goomy the side chick Goomy is okay Oh god Oh my god You're
just okay How does that make you feel?
I'm single
Goomy I think you're getting a little desperate I'm lying
I'm lying Yeah Whoa there's a team over there the side
character holy fuck you're getting fucking roasted right now
you're kidding wait there's like a team to my right as well
I think it's two teams I don't know if it's two teams or not
I didn't hear the are you fucking they EMP me I'm so fucked
I'm backing up fully I don't want to deal with let's
relocate here I'm going to high ground.
What the fuck?
Nico got a car.
What the?
He's pulling up in the whip!
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, I'm going to heal real fast, though.
Oh.
I don't know if it's like...
Wait, what?
Why are they...
Crafting?
Crafting.
In the middle of the fight.
One's over here.
Yeah, I'm going to heal real fast.
literally you know what fuck this i'm ulting okay well
they're running wait what the guy is flesh yeah that guy to
my right oh there's another yeah that's he has white armor
though those two teams
oh careful i only have
because i we're we're surrounded right now i want to fall
back to this building yeah let's fall back to the roof all
right gonna have to slowly crawl up you didn't have to get
to his zone kind of soon i have a redeploy oh yeah we gotta
go to his zone yeah we can just redeploy we don't have to be
here i'm gonna put him down all right bye guys you guys can
fight well i mean the two teams Fighting over there?
What the fuck do you mean?
I have abandonment issues!
Don't wait.
That's why we play Apex.
Where are you going?
Where the fuck go here?
Oh.
We can literally fight them here.
Why did you take another redeploy?
Yes, it was.
Oh!
Oh shit, he's sniping.
everyone's a fucking critic i guess i need like i need like
uh shields if you have any wait they stole our car okay i'm
gonna throw and one bat in here for you wait he's dead i'm
gonna go for that kill because i'm gonna rob him i dropped
my shield for you and it's okay i'm gonna rob this man oh my
god oh shit um Okay, okay, I did not expect him to have a
fucking teammate.
Oh, they're on the building.
Wait, they stole our building?
Okay, we're good.
Why is there on me?
I'm heading over?
Here, my game crash!
No!
Why is my game?
Okay, you guys went fine.
Just don't die.
I'm not dying?
I just don't die.
What do you mean?
Okay, this Apex update.
No, please tell me.
Am I still alive?
I'm coming back in.
Oh, God.
I swear.
This Apex, what do you mean, deserved?
I fucking, I was clutching it.
I saved everybody.
Apex doesn't want me to win.
No!
Let me win.
I was doing too well.
Oh.
I'm alive I crashed before I can't get back Gooby stay alive
Stay alive for me We're all alive we literally killed them
all Oh nice I knew it I was there What?
I was moral support
Don't worry Stay alive don't worry I'm coming back I'm
coming back We're all alive
worry just don't die sorry to god please don't kick me out
for a third time come on i'm here don't worry guys i'm here
now and my game is freaking the fuck out i'm good nice oh my
my game is freaking the fuck go.
Wait, did you guys kill everything?
Whoa!
Okay, as long as I don't look down, we're fine.
Oh, hey.
Everything's okay.
Everything's okay now.
Wait, what?
Wait, behind me?
Oh, I can't look behind me.
No, I'm so fucking nerfed right now!
I can't look behind!
They need to fight in front of me!
I
Walk backwards I can't see
No!
You guys can't kill him, right?
Don't worry, I'm coming over Don't worry, if I walk in the
sideways, we'll be fine Don't worry We killed them, we
killed two of them Okay, I just need to hope that every
enemy shoots in front of me.
Then we should be fine.
As long as they're all in front of me.
Oh, God.
Oh, this is not great.
The zone's coming in.
Oh, this is not great for me.
This is not...
I don't feel so well.
It's okay.
As long as the enemies are in front of me and I never look
behind me, we'll be fine.
Maria, the simulation is breaking.
Doki, we're going behind you.
Wait, no.
No, you're not supposed to.
I can't function.
She can't turn around now.
You have to go in front of her.
There's people in front of me.
Let's kill this team.
Easily.
Wait, where did he go?
Was it solo?
Did I freak out over a solo?
I think I freaked out over a solo.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, that's a rat.
Okay, as long as I'm looking in this general direction,
we'll be fine.
Okay.
Yeah, my textures will be fine.
In front of me?
Oh, my God.
Look at him fucking.
Let's go.
He's flesh.
If you can kill him, do me.
You go kill him, Nico, and I are going to go kill this other
team.
He did what you did!
He made him right behind him!
distraction there's people on me wait what okay okay no
we're coming over here it's not zone though but wait i can
look again i can look all as well oh my god i can look
behind me here where i'm looking where i'm paying yeah i'm
going to the right because that's not because they have the
run from zone.
Oh, actually, they're going all the way bottom.
Wait, army?
It's a squad of three.
Oh, where does...
Whose squad is he from?
Oh, no, I can't look behind!
I thought you were all better.
What happened?
I don't know.
I got sick again.
That's how getting sick works.
You don't just magically get better overnight.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm okay now.
No!
I'm dead.
I'm dead!
2-1, 2-1, 2-1!
I'm gonna reset your game.
Yeah, I'm gonna reset my game.
You know, not be able to look backwards was pretty rough.
Not gonna lie.
I'm gonna reset that shit real fast.
That was...
That was a little awkward.
I could only look one way Alright, no, no Alright, we end
with another win Do you think we do it, Gumi?
Oh?
What'd you say?
We can get a win, right?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, right?
Check drivers?
No!
Because I'm too lazy to restart my PC.
Just wanna play video games.
I just wanna hang out and play video games or invite me yes
ma'am that's me oh we're rookie too come on we can win we
need to win
pike in roller
No way I just said that.
I agree, though.
Go ahead.
GPU is literally dying on stream.
Don't say that.
He's just shy.
My GPU has, like, performance anxiety.
Don't say that.
The more you judge my GPU, the more it's going to freeze.
Don't freak out.
Can't please get a new PC.
Yeah?
For Valentine's Day, can you fly?
Both of us to France.
And then we can get a quisson or something.
It's my dog's birthday.
Why don't you fly over?
Yeah!
Why don't you fly over and celebrate my dog's birthday, huh?
You didn't bite me.
Wait, I'm biting you now.
Surprise!
That's...
Oh my god.
You ruined the surprise.
It wasn't going to be a surprise.
A surprise for who?
For me?
Yes.
Surprise.
You're invited.
You got this GPU.
Doki too, I suppose.
Alright.
Got an R E.
Wait, is there people here?
Yep.
Oh shit, I was not paying attention.
Where though?
Are you lying?
They're near me.
They're literally near me.
No.
Okay, actually I believe now.
That guy might be dead.
I craft one?
I'm gonna help Nico.
Whoa, I'm crazy.
Whoa, Nico.
Nice.
Here.
Here's an armor swap.
Oh, there's blood, Doki!
No!
I'm coming over?
Oh, you're dead.
Oh, my stomach hurt.
Where are they?
Um.
Inside?
Yeah.
I hear someone above me.
Oh, he saw me.
There's someone above me as well.
So, that's what I'm nervous about.
Oh.
My stomach hurt.
Whoa.
Guess I'll have to fucking...
Roll in.
Got you?
That's the person who killed me.
Where's his teammate, though?
Um...
I don't know.
I heard his teammate nearby.
Guess not.
It would be a shame if he just...
now.
What are you doing?
What is that?
What is what?
What's what?
What is that?
What is what?
For free?
Damn.
I got a tiny bit of chippy.
Oh.
Dude, I've been recently drinking this drink.
It's kind of like Sodipop, but it's not Sodipop.
Where is it?
It has, like, apple cider vinegar inside of it.
And it's good for your stomach.
What's it called?
Not sponsored!
Okay, but what's it called?
It's called Poppy.
Poppy?
P-O-P-P-I.
It has apple cider vinegar, and it's really good for your
gut health.
Are you sure?
Are you sure you're not sponsored?
I'm sure.
I just really like it.
Oh shit, wait, what's in that package?
I don't know, that sounds pretty terrible.
That sounds pretty fucking terrible.
Vinegar and what?
Apple cider vinegar?
You've never had that?
No.
I don't like cider in general, to be honest.
I don't like...
Okay, no, it's not cider, nor is it actually vinegar.
It's like...
Oh!
It doesn't taste like it.
Got winging.
Oh.
Wait, what does it taste like?
It just tastes like, um...
It just tastes like...
You know, those busy water drinks with a tiny bit of
flavored juice?
Sparkling water?
Yeah, except like...
But like, but like flavored sparkling water.
Yeah, yeah, exactly like that.
Exactly.
Like, I was like, no, it's amazing!
Alright, how many Poppy sponsors are in here, right?
Like, paid...
How many paid bots are on here, right?
my chat right now it's like anytime you mention poppy all
the poppy bots come into the chat i was like yeah it's so
good you can buy it here right here on this amazon link
right now use my referral code it's a prebiotic it's really
good for you yeah i promise anyway so how many would you
like to click on my referral code oh he's shooting he is
well i need to get closer
Please don't let me die.
I'm gonna kick your ass!
What?
What's going?
I'm fucking shooting them and he's on purpose like blocking
me.
Standing in front of me.
That's my all.
Poppy and bio.
Here, I smoked, but it was 100% not gonna help you.
This deflating for you or some shit.
There's zip bloody on your ass!
I cracked him?
That's fucking right, bitch.
What the fuck?
I cracked this guy, too?
Stupid clones.
Up here.
Yeah, there's two that zipped, but his other teammate
redeployed.
Uh...
I mean, we can...
Do we want to contest their high ground?
Because they're just chilling up there.
Nico's just looting.
I mean, to be fair, it's free loot.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is Mika fighting people?
No, it's them.
Fuses can, like...
The Fuse can, like, chuck names from afar.
Like, from 800 miles.
Dude, that's...
Yeah, that's called Fuse.
I'm not that old, man.
You don't have to talk to me like I'm 50 something.
Okay.
They're running?
Oh shit, Nico's going in.
He's going in!
I just realized you're still white armor.
Yeah.
Go help him!
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're still over there.
Are they still running?
Fucking cowards!
Hey, they're fighting someone else!
Oh, they're going, they're going, they're going up!
Wait, what?
I hear like so many gunshots like here yeah and also here on
that building craft one there's healing oh I couldn't get
him we're like in between a lot of teams I don't know I
don't like this yeah I don't either right there for free
okay let's head over there and see it there on time they're
fighting at it don't worry we're coming in third party wait
it's gone wait what the fuck there's crack one wait can we
still get there what the fuck are they gonna come towards no
it's gone but i think we have to run we can just wait in
front of me
Um, I don't like this.
I smoked again for you.
Thank you.
I think we maybe go...
Oh, wait.
And you got him?
I'm going to drop down.
I'm going to take...
I'm going to drop down from here.
Another squad on him.
Oh, that's not good.
I am sliding into the other squad now.
Squadding.
I'm...
Oh, nice.
Got one?
Wait, he has fucking Digi too.
That's illegal.
Oh my god.
A Dyson one?
I don't know where...
Oh, he's over here.
95 flesh?
Does any of them have R9?
Nope.
I'm gonna loot.
You'll be fine, right?
There.
You guys will be fine.
he has to go to zone anyway right yep hey what zone is this
oh it's zone two it doesn't matter for him
hello you're not gonna be in zone forever right come out
you're really gonna heal in zone
Yeah, you can scan him and see if we can find him.
I don't see him at all right now.
Oh, oh, he's all the way over there.
Well, I'm heading over them.
Hello.
Knock, knock.
Where are you?
Okay.
Alright.
He got stuck on the car.
Right here.
Okay.
That was a little embarrassing for that man.
Alright.
No, bro.
I'm just healing up right now.
I don't think that guy had his driver's license.
Bless you.
I hear people fighting, like, um, here.
Yeah, there's like another fight over there.
All right, you go help Nico.
I'm gonna slowly walk run over.
Yeah.
Poor guy.
Never got his driver's license.
I'm heading over.
There's another...
Oh, wait, that's a replicator over here.
Nice.
I'm almost there.
You're knocked?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm coming.
Nico!
I need help.
Oh, no!
No!
There's another guy!
There's two!
There's another team, there's another team right here.
Don't let him thirst me, I swear to God!
Don't let him thirst me!
I have a wingman!
If they thirst me, they take the wingman!
I just need you guys to know that!
They cannot, they absolutely cannot thirst me.
They absolutely cannot thirst me!
I got them pretty low!
That was a little scary.
Wait, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
I'm safe!
I'm so safe!
There's no way!
Yeah, there's no way!
Provide me, I have Raygun!
all right nice and i can self-heal too see easy and i'm
healing on my i'm healing in my smoke too
all right
oh my god all right i'm fine i'm okay nobody has a med kid
but i'm okay wait they're fighting people behind them too or
they I think you're shooting at you.
I don't think you're shooting at you.
Yeah, Sam.
I think...
Oh, behind me!
Behind me!
I think we gotta back up.
I'm gonna back up fully.
There's too many people on us.
I'm good?
Wait.
I think I see more.
That's not good.
Where?
I don't know.
Marge.
Maybe he can miss...
I swear I lied.
100%.
Okay.
Well, it has to be rat, right?
But men lie all the time, so...
Oh!
Who hurt you?
Oh my god, what a statement.
Oh my god.
They landed up there.
I see them.
They're right in front of me.
I'm looking.
I'm trying to make sure we don't...
I'm trying to make sure we don't get, like, uh, stealth
done.
I'm just looking behind us.
See if there's any rats.
Oh, yeah.
I see a rat.
It's gonna come all the way over to us?
I guess he's gonna take the zip on the other side.
i smell it is he oh there he is wait it's two over here you
run into the house the other one has to run up normal stairs
like a human being oh okay last guy is like below us he's
running all the way across he's like running this way
There's just like, there's like one rat in former squads.
I don't really have an angle on this.
Oh, they're shooting, they're trying to kill the rat.
They killed the rat.
Oh, rat is dead.
Red armor?
Jesus Christ.
Speak again, idiot.
That's a lot of people.
Where do you guys have medkits?
I am one.
And I have a couple syringes.
Yeah, I need some.
I'm on my way.
Nice.
Here you go.
Come on me.
Alright, so...
Wait, where is Zone?
No, they're like right below us.
They're like right below.
There's a whole squad.
A whole squad below us.
Hoop!
Oh my god, please.
Please, I don't have figments.
Chill.
I can drop you a bat right here.
Alright, I'll take that after my shield cells.
Oh, five.
I can just keep my Nika, because he has that box.
Yeah, I can just keep this cross.
You go Nika, and I'm just going to keep this cross.
They're right here.
I wonder if I can nade this.
Or not nade, but alt this.
This.
That should hit them, right?
Should make sure they don't climb up.
Oh, hey, I hit one.
Those are the team right here stuck.
I knocked one.
Knocked on.
Got it behind this thing.
Come on.
He has to come over.
Nice.
My dad.
Are you still in there?
Oh, yes.
I'm on my way, baby girl!
Whoa!
Wait, there's a full team over here too!
Oh my god, it's like a pack of rats!
Oh my god.
Nice.
I'm trying to make sure they don't climb up on us.
Go, Nico, go!
Whoa.
Wait, are you guys okay?
On us, on us.
I'm coming over.
Oh shit, other teams coming over.
Do you have armor swaps here?
There, there.
Nice, okay.
Nice, that's the core I need it.
Don't worry, I have Digi.
Wait, there's still one more.
Where the fuck is the last one?
Where do I have purple?
Do I have Nades?
Oh, I thought that was gonna be closer.
Can I lift those bodies real quick?
I'm going up behind ground.
I might be dead doing this.
On me?
Holy shit, what is your strength?
Oh, he's won, he's won, right here.
This guy's won.
Yeah!
What's...
Oh, Nico's got this.
He can 1v3!
Believe in Nico!
Cluture carry!
Yeah!
He did it!
Cluture carry!
Yeah!
Let him go.
I knew he got this.
I knew it.
I knew Nico's got this.
This is a Nico cam.
What the?
After all the meds and reses I gave you.
Yeah, but like...
But did you kill the last person?
I did, actually.
Wait, did you?
I did, like, 20 damage damage.
Nice.
I did 20 damage to him and I killed him.
Holy shit, we got 667 for that.
Why do you keep swapping the genius?
It's a bug.
It's a fucking apex bug that's been in there for like
fucking years now.
All right.
Look at that.
Look at us, girl.
I knew we could do it.
I knew Nico could do it.
when do we get to play valer and doki sorry what so tomorrow
sorry what do you say sorry i have therapy tomorrow i know
you do but i know what time you have it at i know what time
you have no no no no no no i was including you i literally
heard i don't know what you're talking about
Sorry, when did it happen?
It was 9 p.m.
Ballerant?
Okay, but it's also my dog's birthday.
Okay, how about tonight?
I have to hear nappy-wappy.
Hey!
Alright, LG for me.
Where are you going?
LG for me.
I'm gonna sleep.
What do you mean?
Without me?
Oh my god.
Look what you did.
My game crashed.
That was a sign.
Without me.
Look what you did.
My game fucking crashed.
Do you know it's the worst part?
You're the jump back.
Oh, wait, that's pretty bad.
Wait, usually it gives the jump master somebody else if it
crashes.
Did you pass it to me?
Did you pass it to me, Gully?
No, I didn't.
Did you pass it to me?
Mine automatically passes to Nico.
Did Nico?
Okay, good.
We blame it on Nico again.
There's actually enemies here.
Wait, what?
There's people here.
I just...
Wait, what?
I literally...
Okay.
I just got back.
Okay, cool.
Because I landed you in a semi-alright place.
I don't have a gun.
I have an A.
Oh!
I got all the attachments.
Shut up!
Shut up, Doki!
Don't talk to me right now!
There's no gun.
I have a Mozab.
It's okay.
I kicked the bins.
Okay, sir.
Okay, you guys looted that.
Oh, no.
no i'm p20 right now i'm gonna run this please have mercy
wait what
okay that's not lg
okay not lg not lg not now lg
Look if I crash it doesn't count I need my nap Okay, algae
Are you a quitter?
It's literally a 40 Whoa Whoa, you can't let Nico talk shit
to you like that Whoa, well shit, I'm crying now Look, it's
too done I'm crying now My allergy Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fixed now.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
Ready up, Nico!
Ready up!
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did Nico go?
All men do is eat hot chip, charge their phone, lie, and
abandon us.
Are you okay?
No.
Who hurt you?
Oh, true.
You know my past.
I should say which one.
Sorry,
they all sort of blurred together.
They're all the same person.
He can't do it.
I will use a crutch right now.
He's getting water?
Fucking weak.
It's all about being dehydrated.
Okay, don't get dehydrated, guys, when you're gaming.
All of my dreams I spent.
Or if you need to get this girl a hug or to a cat cafe.
She literally has, like, her dog with her.
You can't save her.
Save me white girl.
Save me.
Have you seen that photo on Mercy?
Which one?
Overlock?
There's so many.
Save me.
White girl.
Yeah, come on.
I swear to I swear to God if I I swear to God.
I swear to God.
I swear I think it's the jump master.
There's no way.
the jump master there's no fucking way i refuse to every
time he goes talking he's like a 4080 every time i have jump
master i swear to god
guys no don't bully my gpu he's shy you're making his
performance anxiety worse He's trying his best.
I'm okay.
We have people on us.
Yay, Kazu.
Dude, what's your dog doing?
He's putting his head on my lap.
Are you just looking at me?
How am I a multi-billionaire?
I lost my job!
Yucky, can you name on my first class ticket to Japan,
please?
I heard you're a multi-billionaire.
From what?
The guy that fucking just met me like four years met me
again after four years?
Four years
Can you please buy me a car?
I don't drive You should ask Nico Nicola Tesla I bet Nico
has multi-million dollars Wow Goodbye I'm fine.
I'm okay.
I don't really want to go back up there.
Oh my god.
You're fucking owned, you freaking noob.
Yeah, bitch.
That'll be fine, right?
You're jumping me, though.
Oh, shit.
He was not fine, guys.
Okay, you res him?
I got you.
Flash?
What are these trying to shoot?
I rise to him.
Come on now.
Alright.
Let's get the alt one.
Easy.
Wait.
Oh, that's our...
It's us Nico.
Nico, you're pissing me off.
Yeah.
You're pissing us off, Nico.
Nico, you're pissing me off.
Why did I get a bat?
I could have gotten barricaded.
I'm going back to high ground.
There must be stuff up top.
The loot.
Nico haters in the lobby.
Heads up.
That's me.
Holy shit.
He's just a little guy.
Can't believe it, Gumi.
How dare you?
What has he done for me?
You're right.
What has Nico...
You're right, guys.
What has Nico done for us?
Nico did
nothing wrong.
Wait, but he did help us win last game.
Are you in denial?
I literally got the last kill.
Yeah, like five damage.
What?
Yeah, do you have proof?
You were down, you were down.
You have proof?
You can't say nothing.
Yeah, I have Shadow Play on- Yeah, I have Shadow Play on-
Yeah, I have Shadow Play on- Yeah, just give me a second.
Yeah, do it, do it right now.
Um, I'm literally busy, I'm playing Apex.
Yeah, do it right now.
You can literally, we literally have no one here.
I said I'm literally playing Apex, don't talk to me.
We literally have no one here.
I can't pause this game.
What don't you understand?
Yes, you can.
We just stand still.
Goomy in denial.
I'm, uh, what are we playing Apex?
We're all literally playing Apex.
What do you mean?
I'm, what are we gaming right now?
Where are the people?
Where are the people that's running at us right now?
I could have scanned.
I mean, we could scan here.
Is there anyone here?
Oh, wait, no, there's no map.
There's only map room scans.
No?
There's a scan right there.
You're right.
It's an online game.
We can never pause.
People were here, though.
I remember when my mom used to yell at me to pause my game
while I was playing MapleStory.
Ah, classic.
Classic moms.
Don't you know?
I'm in this guild party quest.
Ooh!
And...
Wait, there's like people to our right.
Clearly to our right.
They're like shooting at each other.
Why did I see someone in your chat asking if my mom was
single?
Army?
Track?
32 flesh?
Right here?
Oh my gosh, champion's dead.
Am I right?
He's scared.
Jump over.
Trust me.
Jump over here.
Oh shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that was my bad.
I should not have told you to jump over.
That was... Wait, that's another team!
That's another team, that's another team.
Woo!
Oh, Nico, no, don't you go, don't die!
Oh, fuck, okay.
All right.
This is awkward.
Oh, this is awkward.
awkward.
Wait, he... Oh my god, I have to reload.
Fuck.
I didn't even realize.
Woohoohoo!
Wait, that's part of his team?
I thought it was a third.
Third party.
This is a little awkward, guys.
You know what?
I can leave, right?
Oh, fuck.
No, his team, they came behind me!
No!
That was a terrible LT.
But not me.
L was a terrible.
You know what?
We'll do another good one.
JK, this is LG.
You seem a little too excited there.
Whoa, calm down, Nico.
Jimmerdown, man.
he doing taking conduit what is he doing i think he called
your skin ugly wait what better skin how dare you this is
the classic pink skin where the comms at question mark
me maybe don't give me jump or i
yeah there is a pattern we figured out a pattern I crash
when I get jump master
alright where the fuck is the last two players you said I'm
giving you jump that's fucked up Nico I can't believe it I'm
ready to stone we're never playing with Nico ever again
Because do you know what if you ever want to play with Doki
and I you have to be jump exactly, you know what?
Yeah, tell that to him right now Say it come on use your
words ever again if you're not jump master I used my words
We only play with people who are jump master Do you get
that?
Do you understand me?
Shit!
You're like a...
Yes, ma'am.
You're like a mob boss.
Oh my god.
What happened to you?
You've changed, Gumi.
You've changed.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm going to do it.
Oh no!
You're on the list.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm doing it now.
Oh!
If he does it, we leave the game.
You do it, we leave.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, that's what we thought.
That's what we thought.
Oh my god.
What happened to you, Goo?
You've changed.
I played League of Legends.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I play League of Legends every day.
And Valorant?
That's...
Are you okay, like, mentally?
I am surprised you do two of them at the same time.
In front of us!
Oh, go!
I got you?
I cracked one of them.
I cracked the other?
Cracked one?
Yeah, that's right.
Run, bitch.
Yeah.
Yeah, wait.
They're pulling up in the whippy.
Wait, I think that's another...
Not the one?
Wait, is that the same?
Okay, yeah, he is.
I hear someone to my right.
Yeah, here.
Oh, nice.
Nico got it.
Nice.
We all got it.
Yeah, Diane.
Be better.
Yeah.
Diane.
You think you're good at this game?
KAPOIT!
Whoa!
Someone does not like Diane.
What even is in the care package anyway?
Alright.
Grabbing vault prowler.
No long range, which isn't ideal.
I have a hemlock and you want to trade?
Yeah, I'll trade it.
I'll trade it for a pallet.
Nice.
Hey!
Whoa!
I'm grabbing the...
What?
Oh!
Guess I'm not grabbing the fucking bat.
On my ping.
Oh, my battery!
My battery for my white armor.
Where is this?
I don't know.
Did I pick it up?
He's over there.
So far.
Oh my god.
They have like a little head glitch area.
Wingman, Eva, Bo, and Kramer.
Oh, they just took away the prowler for the Eva 8.
I see them.
They're all over there.
I had no reg just now.
No, he knows I have white.
What?
He knows I have white.
Oh!
Shit!
That like booted me off almost.
I thought you were Chinese.
Okay, I don't... I don't have shields anymore.
They took everything from me.
Grab the Custic, you went up there?
Alright, I'm gonna... I'm fucked!
I am so fine.
Oh, I'm gonna bat with my white armor.
Is this...
Is this ours?
I can't tell.
Girl, do we look like we have a Bangalore?
Yes, we do!
What do you mean?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, Nico changes every time I look at him!
Does it look like we have a Bangalore?
I'm fucked.
I got shot from the back.
Wait, are you alive?
I am very afraid for your life right now.
I do not...
Shit!
You are 100% fucked right now.
You know what?
We can do one more game.
We can...
Oh, literally, what the fuck?
You know what?
Yeah, I can do one more.
I can keep going.
The ride never ends.
Doki, are you getting me flowers tomorrow?
What?
Shouldn't you be getting my dog flowers?
I would if you gave me your new address when I asked for it.
I did!
I sent you...
You literally never did!
I did!
No, no, no, no, no, I'm gonna look.
I'm gonna type it.
I'm gonna type for it.
No, no, no, no, I did.
I did.
I remember texting you my address.
You never did.
I did.
I 100% did.
I remember.
It's right there.
Where's right there?
It's literally right there.
Where is right there?
It's right there.
right where it's it's okay that's not my fault you're blind
okay maybe i think i deleted it after
look someone what if someone random five sees it what if you
have your like discord or phone open and if so it sees it i
must have deleted it's gonna look at my phone i what i don't
know someone that steals your phone
And they're gonna look for wife number four specifically.
Yeah.
And some of my text messages were wife number four.
Yeah, because they're gonna be like, what the fuck is wife
number four?
Also I'm number four?
I've known you for seven years.
Let's not.
I've known you for seven years and I'm wife number four?
Let's not pay attention to that.
What do you mean let's not pay attention to that?
I'm gonna die because I'm wife number four.
This is your fault.
I got too distracted for being wife number four.
Who's number three?
Give me the name right now.
Um, her name is Rose.
Who the fuck is Rose?
life who the fuck how long has she known you since 20 2014
wait how many years is that surely over a decade okay okay
okay okay maybe wife number two um christina all right how
many years preschool what the fuck all right wife number one
Before we were even born, our family- Alright, now you're-
Okay, now you're fucking sure all these wives are not- No,
no, you're making shit up.
They're real!
They're- They're not real!
There's no fucking way!
One to three are ten plus years!
Three in a row?
Three in a row.
I have friends.
Hey, wife number one, who?
Who is wife number one?
I literally told you, Priscilla!
You said like you've known her since like fucking before you
were born.
That doesn't make sense.
No, I'm saying that our families knew each other before we
were
born.
Oh.
So it wasn't by choice.
Why?
Are you saying I was an arranged name?
Oh my god, did you know my mom almost put me in an arranged
marriage when I was young?
You're all, yeah, Priscilla.
Alright,
well now I know.
Now I know.
I could never win over, win over Priscilla.
Girl, you literally put me as Callie Girl number four or
something.
I did not put you as number four I just I didn't even have a
number You were the first one I'm the original Callie girl
You're the original Callie girl And so wife number four Well
now I know Who favors who in this friendship You literally
held me gunpoint to bring back the puke emo you literally
it's called a deal it's called a business deal where's that
valorant from the business deal go um oh what do you mean oh
no you're talking but i'm gonna die i'm i'm already dead
we're gonna oh it's okay thank you Girl!
Go, Cavity!
Go!
What?
She's downed already.
I know.
Okay.
We're fine.
Nico will be fine.
See, Nico got it.
Is that everybody?
Get on my chopped liver?
Nice.
I missed when, like, everybody in our lobby was clearly
bronze, or rookie.
I missed that.
When the people get better.
I like how someone was like, yes, I have a wife.
She goes to a different school.
Yeah, you don't know her.
Yeah, you just never met her, you know.
Nico is like...
What did Nico do?
Nico didn't save our lives today, like in this game.
He's literally some guy.
Wake up.
Why didn't he say that about us?
Clearly some girls.
How are we different?
What?
They're simping over some guy.
How are we different, Gumi?
Wake up.
Gumi, how are we different from Nico?
Other than the fact that he's a guy and has a dick.
Okay, simmer down.
Wife number four.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Never talked back to you.
Simmer down.
I'm sorry Please I'm sorry Don't do it Don't lock me in that
room again I'm sorry I got the white tank top ball Holy fuck
This is why Nico is better than us He would never He He
would never Never get the chance to I don't wanna hear it
Nico, please save us Back in the room Back in the room,
milky bird Oh my god What happened to you, Kumi?
Oh my god Valorant Shit Guys, this is not domi-mommy.
Guys, if you think this is domi-mommy, please.
Please.
You need my therapist.
You need...
There are some issues to unpack there.
There is a lot of issues we need to work on.
I played Jet in Valorant.
Oh my god, you're...
You're a Jet, Daddy.
Oh!
This is why I never play Valorant.
I cannot do the e-couples in Valorant.
It's like, Overwatch walked, so Valorant could run.
Do you like him?
Hold on.
What?
Nothing.
Don't worry, wife number four.
Why?
Number four?
Don't worry, wife number four.
you my queen
get down wife number four you're like today today i'll
choose you wife number four oh wife number two go back go
back into the chamber today's wife number four's day time no
you say Oh shit, there's people there.
Guys, okay.
Oh, it's my Discord.
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I thought my game crashed, but my Discord crashed.
My Discord crashed.
It's okay, I'm fine.
I thought it was my apex.
Whoa, what?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I'm getting dead slides.
I'm gonna cover you, Rez.
He'll be fine.
There's two teams, there's two teams.
Nico is just a concubine.
Whoa!
He's a side chick, if you will.
My chat!
My chat's gonna be so angry!
What the fuck is...
Wait, where are they?
What the fuck?
My Discord keeps crashing.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Are you okay?
No, my discord keeps crashing!
My toaster is overheating!
Sorry, and you could get me over there.
Don't worry!
Oh my god, don't worry!
Save me.
Oh my god.
Yeah, maybe it is a PC problem.
Maybe...
Maybe it is a PC issue.
Oh, no.
I can't tell yet.
I'll say it.
Say what?
Nico is but the mashed potatoes and you're the steak to me.
You're the main dish.
Wait, then what's wife number one?
If I am the steak, then what's wife number one?
You're gonna hate to hear this?
I think you need to cover your ears.
No.
I can take it.
can eat that much and i don't really like steak that much um
what um wait i want smashed potatoes to you i don't even
like potatoes that much either oh saying so i will not go
turn the lights off i don't believe it i i mean nothing to
you I prefer seafood and mostly Asian foods.
I'm not even seafood?
You can see my food?
I don't know what that means.
Okay.
Oh, right there!
Cracked him?
Knock?
I got you.
I'm gonna push up a little.
I might be doing something stupid.
I think someone just threw a nata.
me oh i did i cracked him i cracked him oh i did something
stupid i didn't shot in my asshole it's okay nico can rest
me oh he's so dead i i got beamed so hard there is a team
right there on you kumi so i'm just gonna crawl to nico
because i think he can oh wait you did it kumi kumi i'm so
safe i'm so safe kumi i swear to god i have never been this
safe before
All right, nice.
You know what?
Geal swap here?
All right, nice.
I'm gonna...
Okay, I sort of egoed somebody way too hard.
I thought I thought I could live that.
I like how you didn't res me and Nico res me.
Girl, I was fighting for my life.
You're trying to confirm your safety.
I bet if I was wife number one, you would res me instantly.
I kill it.
I don't know.
I have a feeling.
It's just a little feeling I have.
That was the fucking biggest nade I've ever seen.
They cooked that shit up.
I don't think we should head to Nico.
Go!
Okay, give me your shield.
Give me your shield.
Okay.
I'm so dead Nico no Nico Oh okay Why are you still in
bronze?
We gave you five hours You know I can do one more I can't do
another The guy that killed us They were in princetown Oh We
gave you five hours to climb out of bronze God, I can't do
nothing I think my PC is overheating because it's so fucking
hot Wait, my window's closed again Oh my god, my PC's hot
too Wait, I think my mom closed the window Let me open it
again My room's 69 degrees
I I We're good Dude, my room is 20 degrees right now,
Celsius.
My room's, like, super fucking hot right now.
I need to, like, buy a fan for my room.
I have, like, a heater for my room, but I don't have a fan.
Alright.
Okay.
This is LG for reels.
For real, real.
I promise.
Why not full?
Why not?
What the fuck?
Why not full aircon?
I do.
But, like, um...
My room is literally I it's a box.
It's like a anyway I'm booting up my game back Nico It's
like a greenhouse because there's like five windows
surrounding my room Two of the walls is like windows So it's
like literally the Sun shines in and then it's a fucking
greenhouse So it's not great They're just like my beautiful
flower for real.
Yay.
I'm a dying flower.
Yeah, it's like a sunroom.
It's so bad.
It's either way too hot or way too fucking cold.
There's no in between.
Oh my god, we're here.
Gumi, you're a jump master.
There's a team here.
Where are you going?
Are we going here?
Shit loot?
I know.
Someone pinged it.
I guess we go here.
landed here, so we should be safe.
Alright.
LG for real.
No joke.
I need to take a nap.
No joke this time for real.
Don't worry, I yelled at Nico for you.
Oh, you did?
Thanks.
Yeah.
Yeah, but you might as well do it again.
Teach him a lesson.
No, I'm a nice person.
Screw you, Nico.
Who said that?
Oh my god.
Was your window open?
Goomy?
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Don't turn around.
Don't turn.
That ghost.
Don't look back.
Kini top?
Oh, Kini top.
Alright, I'm ready to play.
This is LG for reals.
No more, no more not LG.
No more fake outs.
I'm for real LG.
I've never been so LG in my life.
How the fuck scan this?
There's people over here.
Let's go.
Go.
Sorry, Nico.
I'm just cranky.
I haven't had my afternoon nap.
See you in voice.
Apologize to him right now.
Nico.
Ah!
Never do that again in front of me.
Never do that.
I feel so tired.
One four.
He ran.
He's running like a little baby.
Go Nico, go.
Oh.
Where are they?
Uh, they ran down.
They ran all the way down?
Wait, there's a wench.
They didn't run all the way down, liar.
Wait, there's one right here, right here.
Oh.
Boomi, no, don't die.
There's one on me, too.
Oh, I'm dead.
No!
I didn't get my one!
Maybe I'm also tired.
That's fine.
I believe.
Look, he had a destructor.
Look, all I'm saying is if I had his same loadout, I would
have been alive.
That's all I'm saying.
I'll leave you wholeheartedly.
No, wait, I swear, watch.
I'm gonna become the seer.
Okay, I might be dead because, um...
Okay, yeah, I'm 100% dead.
I am.
I'm so fucked.
Please, someone, defend me.
I'm streaming.
I'm streaming, defend me.
Where's his load out?
Wait.
Where is his load?
Where is the guy?
Where the fuck is the guy that killed?
There he is.
Oh.
Alright.
Who shot us earlier?
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, okay.
I didn't want to fight in zone, but I guess we will.
I craft one.
Well, I'm outside of zone.
Oh, you guys are so...
Balls deep.
Yep.
Um...
I don't know how.
They're flesh.
Someone go to zone.
Goodbye.
Wait, what?
Oh hey, I got a kill!
I did that.
You smile.
It was me smile.
See, I told you, the moment I take this man's loadout, I
win.
Even though he died by a ring.
Can't wait to be quick to me, yo.
Builder's just gonna take the car and then come back here.
Oh wait, why are they all dying in a ring?
Do they not have heals?
Probably not.
I guess not.
Oh, bastards alert!
Oh, I'm coming over.
Bastard alert, Nico.
Get them.
Where are they?
Alright, I opened the door so they all know we're here now.
Wait, where are they?
Okay.
Okay, I have white armor.
I'm a little scared.
Um, there's that team behind us as well, so we gotta be
careful.
pushing up you could just ate one of my shots there's a guy
right here in my front of me
knock one knock two there's so one more guy whoa where is he
there see I told you my loadout there's still more there's
still more no no no cover cover I have gold I knew it I knew
my loadout is a heath.
I knew it.
I don't have any long range, so I require you guys to do all
the long range for me.
Where's your teammate?
Oh my god, he's in front of you!
I can't cancel it.
Is she asshole, dude?
Okay, I'm here.
Oh, can I get to you?
Wait, what?
Is that another team?
Wait, I hear people.
Oh, shit!
Hello.
There you go.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
It's all about this new loadout.
Do you have a master?
Oh, I just realized I haven't upgraded at all.
What do people use?
Increase Tachro range.
Gain attack.
It'll charge but have a shield.
Shield regen duration.
Wait, which one is good?
for conduit split charge or radiant transfer chat backseat
time i haven't had time to learn meta
oh my god too many maybe which one
which one guys probably transfer
scanning that one guys oh wait there's someone in front of
us There's a team here.
An R.
Oh, I can shield them both in the first one.
You're right.
Okay.
It's a caustic in there.
I kind of don't want to go in there.
It's too late.
I'm going in.
Girl, I literally see you walking up to the entrance.
You can turn around.
I'm going in.
I ulted.
What are you gonna do?
Kill us?
See?
Look, we're five.
Oh!
Whoops.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh, there's his ult coming in!
Come on, get over here, Nico.
Are they running from us?
They're running from us.
Oh, Nico, I don't have...
Nico, please.
Oh, there's a guy there.
He's still there.
I cover.
I'll cover.
You res?
I can cover.
I cannot cover.
We don't need more.
Here.
I gave it to the wrong person.
We knocked one.
Unless he res.
He res.
Please get closer.
I only have short range.
Okay.
I have a Rita play if we need it.
We're in zone though.
I don't think.
I'm gonna get a cross.
Oh, never mind.
I can't get the cross.
I'm not batting a bat.
You fucking kidding me.
I'm batting now.
I'm worried about our backs, though, to be fair.
I knocked one.
62 acoustic.
I'm pushing up.
Flash?
He's running?
He's running like a little bitch?
Wait, it's two.
Oh my god, I need a bat then.
He's full running.
Nico's got it.
I knew it.
I can always believe in Nico.
Why are they...
What are they doing?
They're so scared.
Goomi, run after him.
Jump!
I'm running!
Where did he go?
I'm gonna craft Wait, where the fuck did he go?
Wait, he disappeared
Wait, what?
I hear something.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, he's dead to the ring.
Dead.
Wait, that's the team that tried to kill us last time in the
original house.
Did you know what the You know when we were at the little
the towers?
That was them.
They just finished the fight.
That's last two.
Last two squad.
Last two squads.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I don't know if this is going to hit, but I'm going to hell
marry this.
It'll be so smart.
Trust me.
It is definitely not close to anybody.
I cracked one.
Oh shit!
Anyway.
Am I left?
Behind us?
On me?
Nice.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, over there!
Wait, what?
What is happening?
They're super spread.
That's what's happening.
Is this shield swap here?
That's fine, I cover.
Yeah, they're so far, they're so far.
I took this shield swap.
Holy shit, they're so far.
Poor guy.
I'm gonna do you.
I'm going in!
No regrets!
I'm in!
Okay, maybe a little regret.
Okay, little regret, little regret, little regret.
Nico's got this.
Okay, okay!
Alright!
Look at that, I knew this was a real LG.
We did it, bench time, bench time.
We did it.
Yay!
Good night.
Good night, Gumi.
Thanks for playing with me.
See you for Valorant tonight.
Huh?
What?
For Valorant 9 p.m.
Bye-bye!
Sorry, you're breaking up on me.
sorry i'm not picking up with you sorry sorry you're you're
you're sorry the call there's something wrong that okay oh
people beep that was fun i had a great time i really enjoyed
it shout out to uh shout out to kumi for uh playing some
games with me and also we finally were reunited with nico
from four years ago that was actually crazy when he was like
we used to play together season three i was like whoa i
played with a lot of people on season three sorry nico that
was crazy um but yeah shout out to goomy for hang out with
me today and um it was just really nice to just you know pew
pew and have fun and just not think about anything you know
it's just it's it's it was really nice i really did enjoy it
but yeah i hope this was like a nice time to just you know
just laugh and have fun and forget about what's going on in
the world for a brief moment and I enjoyed my time.
Thank you everybody for hanging out.
It really made me very happy.
Gaming and Apex is such a huge comfort for me, especially
when, you know, when things aren't looking great for me
mentally.
I really just, it's just nice to just hang out with friends
and being able to, you know, play Apex and not forget what's
going on and just, you know, have some fun and laugh and i
really appreciate everybody for hanging out with me um even
though this isn't really is not monetized or anything i
didn't want to receive any monetization i just want to hang
out and enjoy my time with my friends um but yeah i had a
great time guys um i guess uh thank you everybody um as
always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye